or our ball so I really believe I really
actually believe your take on the
business of music the b2c b2b correct
take on music's interesting interesting
to me because I think your perspective
could have me look at it differently and
allow me to activate areas that exist
that we haven't sort of and you'll know
what and you know what the best part is
you you and this is just how we're gonna
start jamming right from the get I'm so
crazy on this I'm going to see
everything diarrhea and throw up like
you know what that happens we're ly when
you're really sick and you'll know what
to do with it I have no heart I don't
give a [ __ ] for real you know what to do
but I know intuitively and I don't know
the music this is at all but I know this
the famous of Spock and there's so much
opportunity for disruption in an
interesting way here's why the money is
not at the end consumer in the way that
it always was we all know that screaming
all this can make money on the records
whatever that but there's so much money
in brand so much which is what I've been
spending the last seven years on and
there's so much money in access so much
and you gotta understand that will go
away for a very long time and you have
all the permission to own the [ __ ] out
of that
no no way I'm crazy
we're talking about my body
[Music]